et maintenant en vie sociale est
toujours
s
si albert dupontel
ali revanche soir en garde à vue une
interview de hans blix là c'est étonnant
quand même il dit oui bah oui avait pas
de preuve les mecs 12 ans complètement
manipulé ça s'appelle se [ __ ] de la
gueule du monde
voilà entier voilà georges marchais
tanon tu les démos et voilà
à un message de georges pour dire toi
même alors albert dupontel acteurs haute
réalisateur aujourd'hui c'est l'acteur
que nous recevons pour un film de
nicolas boukhrief qui s'appelle le
convoyeur avec jean dujardin françois
berléand vous sorti le 14 avril
c'est le troisième film de nicolas
boukhrief et le film se passe dans une
société de convoyage de fonds
c'est la première fois et c'est bizarre
d'ailleurs ni les français ni les
américains ni personne n'avait pensé à
ça avant alors c'est marrant c'est qu'on
voyait assez des ouvriers en fait on y
gagne 1 oui enfin c'est bizarre c'est
des mecs qui gagnent un salaire de
misère pour transporter des millions et
s'étaient taris gré en vie oui ça fait
partie des aberrations de la société
voilà actuel de la même façon qu'il ya
un président des etats-unis qui dit que
les arbres n'existe pas il ya on donne
1000 euros par mois des ti pour
transporter des millions d'euros dans
les fourgons c'est un peu un peu
aberrant tpo creed un peu fructueux un
plan anti sociale comme vous dites c'est
très bien documenté une enquête qui a
été fait par par une journaliste avant
étaient vraies dans quel pas tout tout
tout maison pas démenti la globalité
alors voilà c'est un film qui était un
suspense sur un fond sociétal
on pourrait dire un si on voulait parler
que dans les mots ces tables très bien
c'est un film noir un film de genre qui
rend compte la vie d'un groupe
emblématique de la société actuelle
c'est le mec paumé qui sont armés avec
une tentation permanente évidemment
depuis que le fric qu'ils transportent
ouais ouais c'est un petit peu ça quand
même un paradoxe alors les bus votre
personnage alexandre se fait engager par
cette petite société de transport de
fonds
les affaires vont pas bien on parle de
vendredi lents
dépôt de bilan vente aux américains donc
un certain stress d'entreprise
effectivement qui doublait d'un stress
et d qui sort du fourgon qui peuvent
faire de leur vie et au travail ils
peuvent perdre leur boulot ça fait
beaucoup quand même
alors en plus cette petite société est
victime de deux braquages répétés alors
on se demande s'il n'a pas une
complicité entre les convoyeurs et les
truands qui est qui les attaquent et on
se demande qui vous êtes au départ on
vous voit arriver alors on se dit c'est
un paumé qui a trouvé un boulot il fait
ça parce qu'il sait pas quoi faire
d'autre
ensuite on pense vous êtes un flic
peut-être qui est en train de
s'infiltrer la société pour savoir qui
organise ces braquages
on pense déprime derrière un braqueur
évidemment je vais pas vous dire
espérant conjoncture c'est une des
forces du film c'est 45 minutes on sait
pas ce qui se passe ni ce qu'il vient
faire
ouais et pourtant présent son fauteuil
et vous tir de cinq minutes quand le
mobile apparaît du monsieur je le trouve
très touchant très émouvant est leur foi
voilà